folks joe derosa here from the taste
buds podcast
you want to see me on the road come see
me i will be in austin texas at the
creek and cave may 22 20th and 21st
that's four shows only
i'm gonna be
doing more dates coming up soon
unfortunately i had to cancel my west
coast dates so i will not be performing
in irvine california or in san diego now
as i was supposed to in april but come
see me
in may at the creek and cave in austin i
promise i will make up those west coast
dates as soon as humanly possible and if
you are in the new york area come to
jelly roses at 174 rivington street
we are open tuesday through sunday get a
drink get a sandwich get both have a
good time uh if you want to know about
my show dates go to joederosainfo.com
if you want to know about joey rose's
info you go to
joeyrosesnyc.com i hope that's not too
confusing at joderosa on instagram and
twitter
i'm talking to you directly
i'm coming on tour and i don't always do
it so you got to come see me and here we
go april 15th and 16th i will be in
louisville and evansville april 23rd and
24th i will be in tulsa and oklahoma
city beacon theater new york city first
time may 14th there's going to be some
surprise guests there and that's all i
can say but you do not want to miss that
and i'm going out west cali i'm finally
coming to you i'm going to be in san
diego on may 21st and at the wilton
theater in los angeles for the first
time ever on may 22nd everything is
available right now at savolcano
comedy.com a little bit
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds taste
buddies welcome to t-a-s-t-e
butts
good to be back it's good to be back it
feels
so good to be back
let the ladies and ladies and gentlemen
gentlemen introdu
i walked out of my build my my door the
other day and my neighbor i heard
just loud loud and and when i got up to
his door when i was passing his door he
was just blasting eminem yeah and just
singing it
but like with gusto is that bad
no and then he was coughing like you
know how big biggie smalls coughs in the
beginning of it like an interlude yeah
it's pretty thick
it's gross he was coughing like he was
intimately caught coughing like that and
singing eminem oh god yeah has that ever
happened to you have you ever been
caught singing publicly
oh yeah many times many times
uh
it's a little weird but like i don't
care i air guitar often when i walk
you said that like it was so normal it's
not no i know it's not i'm saying like i
don't you're just walking down the
street
if i'm listening to if i'm listening to
something like that sometimes i will
like air guitar
guitar or no
a little bit like no no no but i mean
you do then or you don't
you know you could play chords and you
could play a song yeah i can oh i can't
yeah i used i used to play a little
guitar
guitarist but i was capable enough so
when you do the air guitar is it just
like i would do it or is it based on
actual chords
i i i assume i'm doing something that's
reasonably or you know really accurate i
guess oh you think when guitarists do
air guitar they're using chords
i'm like looking at the show v is here
today and she's behind a tripod so much
i i don't know i'd love to go to the air
guitar um
so i was gonna in my bar back in the day
i was gonna host the battle of the air
bands
i had this whole thing planned man
there's gonna be a tournament this would
be a cash prize and i i was gonna sync
up with this band that already exists
called the buddhist band they might
they're great funk band from staten
island they like tour the world they are
amazing and i don't
i don't do any of that but i was going
to be the lead singer now you got to
lip-sync too sure yeah and i never came
to fruition but uh it's never too late i
don't think there's any age cap
they were on stage once at a sold out
show and i i begged them if i could come
on stage and play with them and they're
my friends they're all from the
neighborhood and stuff and uh they said
what are you gonna play and i said i'll
play the spoons they're like
they were at one point like a 12 piece
bin horns brass section everything and i
got up on a sold out show and i just
started they set up a low mic like a low
like thigh level mic and i just started
slapping the spoons against my leg now i
don't think i was contributing much
there but
mark my words i'm saying it here right
now
so new salsa windfall record coming very
soon
first if if we do a video
if we do a video the video will
be four very old men
airbanding the song
that's what it'll be
oh wow that's for elderly oh that's so
fun did you just think of that right now
i did 10
you got to put me in i need to film that
yeah yeah that's such a fun idea yeah to
be for old men that's a fun idea it is
right yeah that's going to be the video
everybody wow
american rob messel named air guitar
world champion
um
by the way
what does that come with does that come
with a cash prize please because i think
you do get a prize yeah i guess so right
there's got to be something how much do
they make right here there it is
custom-made guitar
oh my god
made by brian maybe from queen that's
pretty cool wow
wait wait wait wait wait sounds like
what sense are you running wait i'm
sorry one year brian may leakage
donated oh donated a vox
bm okay
brian may donated a prize one donated an
amplifier you said he built and donated
a guitar i was trying to put the two
sentences together and it's the way i
wanted to i understand i'm just trying
to get i'm just trying to where did this
guy come from oh my god what
oh no related to air guitar i thought
they made 95k a year for a minute i was
like i'm about to quit wow
this was brought here a while back i
don't know who i don't know
who is this the guy again it's from an
r.l steinberg from goosebumps it's from
goosebumps he's the you know that yeah
knight of the living dummy this is he's
the star but i forget the dummy's name
but this is the most famous of the rl
stein you know is that correct yeah
that's his banger so arl stein i know
that he's world famous right he for
scaring children for children's books
but how do you know what that is
uh i hang around a lot of kids and we
talk
kids are always welcome down at joey
roses that's at 174 rivington no id
necessary sandwiches in the back
that's not true
uh we have to make
we have to make a merch speaking of
march
we'll we'll do it we'll do it yeah we'll
do it but we got to make one that says
children are always welcome in chile no
no we're not making that we're not
making yes the uh
this guy how do i know it games of the
front sandwiches in the back
i i'm a big uh horror fan as you know
and
i know who r.l stein is just by proxy of
being a horror fan even though he's a
little after my time but i knew what
goosebumps was when i was a k you know
teenager i'd heard of it i was a little
too old for it but as i got older
i started writing
i write i've had i've been i don't know
if you know this i've had horror fiction
i've written published like i did not
know that it has happened and i started
trying to sell i'm still trying to sell
it i'm trying to sell a children's
horror book
because it's like my favorite thing was
as a kid i loved it like r.l stein yeah
a little scarier but yes so when i
started putting that together i went and
started watching r.l stein goosebumps
and are you afraid of the dark which was
the nickelodeon sort of equivalent of
that show and i learned all about the
oral stunt characters you started
watching it was it a cartoon
it was uh no no
well he wrote books and they made a
live-action series called goosebumps and
the most famous goosebumps episode or
character was called night of the living
dummy and it was this guy there is that
him right there um i forget his name
though
slappy that's right that's his name
that's slappy yeah yeah that's pretty
funny man and he is for pretty creepy
he's pretty creepy is that let me see
does that jaw move is that like a pull
to back and he talks
oh wow that's creepy as [ __ ] he's got a
smooth head i like rubbing his smooth
head
i think my favorite thing him up here my
favorite thing about rl stein is that in
the movie he was played by jack black
r.l stein was played by it slappy was
played by blockchain
no but slap jack black was also slappy's
voice oh really yeah
was the
why is jack black playing r.l stein in
the movie isn't rl stein the author they
did a goosebumps movie where
where like yeah where they made it like
uh they made it like rl stein was this
guy whose books actually came to life
and
you know they did a hyper reality
version what do you think the best like
kids movie of all time was to you horror
either
anything to find kids because i think uh
yeah goonies is tremendous obviously i
think the dark crystal is a masterpiece
oh dark crystal was great the secret of
jim henson is a really creepy gentleman
the secret of dark crystal was amazing
the secret of nim that's a great one
yeah yeah
labyrinth is great how about shout out
never ending story bro
never an extraordinary
does hook hold up oh so i'm told that
people love hook to pieces it holds up
and it's a traditional classic i've
never seen hook i don't think it holds
up at all i think it's very
it's
hook is really at the very beginning of
like the schmaltzy robin williams era
yeah and i think that that really bleeds
through that said there's wonderful
performances in the movie i i just i'm
not schmaltzy i've never heard that
schmaltzy schmaltzy
is like like uh like uh like modeling
like like uh
indulgently emotional
okay like like the robin williams was
like bicentennial man like all that
stuff he did where it was like patch
adam's patch adams you know that kind of
stuff
you know a lot of them don't hold up i
don't know what happens is you see it
then you're attract you're attached to
the nostalgia of it and you're attached
to how you felt the first time you saw
it that happens with everybody everybody
thinks this [ __ ] is still the best
wait stay there is there is rich voss
one of the lost boys
[Laughter]
oh oh that's him that's him
right there
it looks just like oh my god that's
uncanny wait those are all the lost boys
now yeah that's them like grown up now
[Laughter]
shout out rich moss
as well we love him i just spent a week
with rich at south by southwest
and man it was so fun i went so i did a
bunch of shows in philly and then i
would shout outs philly punchline philly
punchline thank you thank you amazing
shows amaze how many clubs would do this
by the way amazing shows my whole family
comes in for the saturday early show i
talked to my mom the next day she goes
did you pick up our tab and i go
i was like oh [ __ ] i should have and i
didn't yeah and i was like no mom i'm
sorry and she goes well somebody did the
club paid for my whole family's tab they
didn't even tell me they just did it
they didn't get tipped for it either
what do you mean yes what do you mean
they didn't get tipped should we call
them
you didn't even know there was a bill so
i would add you to them tip on the bill
no my family left it they got a bill
that said this has been taken care of
thank you oh and your family left a tip
i'm sure they did well why don't we get
on the phone and find out right right
i think that's i think that's i think
that is the the top move right now in
the podcast let's get to one there's
nothing you can really say that's going
to top that suggestion let's get your
mom on the phone and ask what they
tipped i don't want to get her on the
phone let's get her on the phone let's
find out what they ate and what they
tipped on top can we please do a mother
battle where you bring your moms in oh
yes
my mom my mom will battle
not his mom but my mom in general just
battles
every sentence that comes out of her
mouth is a battle do you want me to try
calling call her call yeah
i could be like look up she's like
that's not up
yeah no i know wait for that episode now
i'm familiar yeah i think it's coming up
oh my god how about we each battle our
own mom on it
no you just haven't yet
[Laughter]
hold on i'm calling all right
she's dodging your calls
they might be out for the day really
they're out gallivanting
really
they're out traipsing about how does it
take a day trip
very well very well
so i was i was telling the story how you
guys all came out to the early show
if the family left a tip
yes we did all right excellent so that's
that's base one covered we weren't sure
because he said the clown how nice that
of the club to to to comp it and i said
oh my god if they compt it nobody knew
then they didn't even get tipped and he
said that you did tip and they said well
let's get him on the phone say hello see
how much they tipped
and then also on a scale of one to ten
what they thought of joe seth
go ahead mom
i don't know how much the other guys
laid on the table but they put something
out there
that's my dad by the way yeah of course
he said go ahead mom and then
yeah no dad
would you say you but you left a tip you
don't have to get into how much and then
what did you think of the set
the set was very good john i mean
fantastic yeah you know after all that
time you've been away i mean we thought
it was really good and you know your
state's presence and everything was just
fantastic you know and just like i sent
you my even i text my message i said you
still got it and you haven't lost it so
you know you really
i love it all right
i love you guys wait wait wait so joe
so i love that i love it to pieces uh
jimmy and joe have been performing
together a lot i love his set too he
does have some dark material you guys
like you guys are able to find the humor
in his dark stuff
we can't hear you go ahead say it again
i said he does he does have some dark
material are you guys able to find the
humor then and like the darker stuff he
does
oh yeah yeah
sometimes i think just like
him first few times we sat in his
audience right it was kind of little
gunshot to say because he would say you
know my mom and dad are in the audience
so i got to be careful what i say but no
don't hold anything back he never does
hold anything back you know so that's
great
wow you just let it fly thank you all
right should we ask what he ate as a
child should we get something today
what mom
what are you guys comparing today
first the episode we're about to do
right now is chicken fingers versus hot
dogs
so
can you guys each tell me what you would
choose each if you have to choose
between chicken fingers or hot
dogs hot dogs all right i go
the uh
ballpark frank's all natural beef hot
dogs great that's my favorite all right
and mom what about you
chicken fingers
all right uh all right
look at that well i am taking chicken
fingers today and uh joe is taking hot
dogs yes yes
and then good
pimp pimper producer before we go wants
to know
ask them what what food they've seen you
eat the most in your life what food have
you seen me eat the most in your life my
life your life our lives
thank you monster
wow
jesus and you have the unmitigated gall
to come out here and taunt me to think
i'm better than everybody else and
you're eating surf and turf as a toddler
jesus christ
i mean
look i mean what you're exposed
[Laughter]
yeah muscles and clamps too well i never
liked even as a kid i wasn't big into
sweets i liked i liked like yeah i liked
like fish
yeah what what todd would kids bring in
a brown lunch bag full of clams to
school
it was like you and norton
what yeah yeah
what mommy
i used to have to go to the lunch
weekend and get them hands
like to eat on the spot you mean
yes
i can imagine you at the like the lunch
table in the cafeteria and people like
yo can i get you want to trade can i get
a half of that turkey sandwich and like
what do you have to offer you're like
[ __ ] fresh clams bro
[Laughter]
shy i just shucked them
but it is true i always had propensity
for for cold cuts from a young age
also too we argued last week corned beef
versus corned beef on rye versus ham and
cheese and sal couldn't believe that i
loved corned beef on rye since i was a
kid
and i told the story of you taking me to
baine's deli at the king of prussia
plaza food court and giving me my first
corned beef on rye remember that
that's great yeah
all right
well you're an odd duck i am i am i am
all right i love you guys i got to go
joe was staying with us
one night right and it was about 11 30
and just i'm hungry so what do you feel
like you i don't know i want to go get
some clams so we traveled about three
different stores to go find some clams
just sending your parents on a multiple
stop goose chase
each at what age no this is like a year
ago
[Laughter]
chocolate cake something with chocolate
chocolate icing right we must have went
through five different stores
all right well
thank you for this i love you guys
i love you too all right
i'll talk to you guys soon bye guys
well
coddled
fancy pants joe
just being ushered around just driven
around like miss daisy to find surf and
turf and shellfish
at a late hour he always says you're on
your cloud so yeah you always say like
you always say dude like i like this
this [ __ ] t-shirt is 15 years old
your your mother's liquefying steak and
and lobster in a blender and giving it
to you in a bottle as a 24 month old
fair enough
[Laughter]
quick shout out before we continue this
artwork is unbelievable
we got a beautiful i guess that's an oil
acrylic or oil painting that is
gorgeous let me find her and uh you see
joe there as the uh
would use the rook assault
who's the per who's the blueberry's
farook assault yeah yeah yeah
pimp is oopalumpa
and then we pull in the seinfeld ref
yeah right that's kramer turkey yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah those are because
the turkey reference isn't to willy
wonka is it
no that's what do you think that's
kramer turkey yeah yeah what about that
chip which on the end there that looks
photorealistic it does that looks great
uh and there's there's
david is she in is she
lady did this uh stephanie trobe at
s-t-p-h-t-r-a-u-b-527
thanks stephanie
uh
i love it
uh we we are always
taken back by people's talents and and
and your uh
your time to do this for us it's
freaking great and we're starting a p.o
box so if anyone else wants to add to
the collection oh we're welcome we got
some bangers so we would love it but
that is that's something else the uh the
uh
we should say this probably actually
because we are starting a p.o box guys
i'm not being presumptuous
i just have a feeling because people
tend to do this joe has a feeling send
you stuff and given this is a food show
i feel like that'll be double don't send
us any food at all don't send any we
can't it's just too crazy of a world we
can't eat it it's he will not he will
not share it
i don't want you to waste your money and
time sending us food and with good
intentions when we're not going to be
able to eat it like don't don't just
don't say no don't send that yeah
actually just send us proof of the
artwork and then i'll give you the
address yeah you know that's but people
do that they'll still like like
sometimes people like to like come to a
show and bring you like brown don't
bring people yeah people bring me phone
people bring me food at like they'll
come backstage or all like
outside or
literally they'll have to be sitting in
their seats and i see tupperware and i'm
just like what's that now like oh we
baked you and i'm just always like like
i cannot eat your house food like you
can't bring me something that's not
factory sealed
i don't know you right i mean thank you
no i always open it up and i pass it
around the crowd for whoever wants to
eat it and let them let them [ __ ]
drop like flies yeah and then like like
a dictator would yeah yeah yeah
just to wipe out the whole three first
three rows it's like heaven's gate yeah
yeah yeah yeah exactly um you did let's
let them eat the correct
food if you want to send some candy or
whatever send anything you want don't
send homemade perishables but uh
so anyway i was saying shouts out to
philly and then i would and then i went
down to south by southwest from philly
and voss was there he spent many hours
with voss had a great time
he's so funny we judged gross battle it
was was mean that's fun we did an 11 p.m
rose battle the judges were vos me blair
saki who's the best she's great
and um
oh god who was the oh and mike lawrence
who's [ __ ] hilarious you know
uh it seemed like in a while
it was great seeing him it was great
seeing everybody we had we just had a
blast and then i did a sandwich summit
at the creek and cave where i hosted a
round table discussion
with three sandwich makers from around
austin
texas uh i had joey roses shipped in
overnight
so those sandwich makers tasted your
products yeah and it was shipped over
tonight
it was wild how did it how to fare
it held up good it held up i mean
obviously fresh on the spot is going to
be better but yeah they're look at this
i didn't even know we got press
that's awesome but yeah that's a that's
a sh oh that's from daily shopping but
that's the uh that's a shot from it
pepitone and blair
sat in to do like
you know color commentary as comics
and dude it was filled it was packed 5
p.m it was awesome so what was so what
was the takeaway what would we learn at
the sandwich helmet
uh we we discussed so this guy on the
end what do you mean what
what was it summit
so is there a piece between you all now
fun way to say it
now this guy in the end his name is mo
he has a thing called jew boy burgers in
austin
he talked about his entire
oh that sounds cool it's amazing i want
to do a kennish battle but i'm afraid
that i found out not a lot of people
outside of like
like
metropolitan cities know what a canister
is it was so good and then derek has a
place do me a favor but before you
continue if you know what a knish is and
or if you don't know what a canis is
sound off in the comments we want to get
a i want to just get a litmus test on
whether we should have a knaddle
um derek is the is next to him he has a
play a deli i think it was called
outside land outlands oh outer oh god
i'm sorry derek i'm blanking on the name
of your deli
and then brian had a place called bird
bird biscuit where everything is served
on biscuits and he brought some of his
biscuits they were unbelievable what's
the other side deli that's what uh
derek's singing and then blairstocki and
eddie pepitone set in sat in and
they were both hilarious but eddie is so
funny
cause he kept yelling
like he he was like
eddie pepperon staten island now yeah i
know he's the best but we would be like
we'd be like why don't you put tomatoes
on your burgers or whatever and then
they would bed he would be like i'm here
to expose the truth
big oil is taking over this country
he would just keep yelling stuff like
that
in between us talking about like what
our approach to like salami was or
whatever dude it was so
funny eddie pepitone is still one of
those guys i can never pull it off but
even now he'll wear like a like a bowl
like a fedora and like an earring yeah
yeah he's one of those guys that just
like
till it till till the end he's like that
hip cat he's yeah he's great
and uh everybody everyone was it was
awesome it was just awesome how did you
recruit the people for the sandwiches
who chose them the festival sent me a
list of people and we we reached out to
people that we thought might be
interested and
and those were the three people that
responded and enjoyed what kind of local
food did you get into just
well their their local stuff it was all
like like i mean off stage
oh
yeah how was it oh i
i took actually did some
i did i took some selfies and stuff
while i was in philly because i hit a
couple sandwich places in philly
you know what you should do you know how
like they do like the freaking like
pizza bite or whatever you should you
should go to a sandwich place take a
bite i'll give you one i know i'm gonna
start doing that i mean i don't think
that's patented to take a bite
i'm gonna start i'm gonna start doing
that and then we're doing this new house
you're on the road and [ __ ] yeah yeah
with this these shots i was doing were
kind of the beginning of it so like i'm
going to we're going to start doing this
hashtag that's called joey rhodes's
so like when i go on the road and i
travel around i take you know i hear
this look at this crazy how do you spell
joey rhodes's r-o-a-d-s-e-s
joey rhodes is okay i can see it so then
like so like one of the things i did was
like cheat like was the geno stakes in
the airport we haven't posted it yet but
you know stakes in the airport i was
like i was like this is why we don't do
a cheesesteak because the geno steaks in
the philadelphia airport is making a
better cheesesteak than you'll ever have
anywhere is that right yeah so like why
would we even try to go up against it
you know what you do you write r o as
capitals
and then a d
little and then scs is capital so you
see the roses
but you see the roads oh yeah that's
really smart i had a scholarship to
college okay
don't be on my this is the jenny's this
is for my thing though this the joey
rhodes will be on the julie rose's
account i do want to shout out jenny's
because they send me i love them they
contact me and they contact uh the
people i work with they send me jenny's
ice cream all the time and uh last year
they came out with an everything bagel
and cream cheese ice cream i didn't get
it it was limited edition it sold out
they came out with it again they just
sent it can i tell you
that it is so delicious it's good is it
not it's good it tastes like an
everything bagel with cream cheese and
it doesn't sound like that will be good
in an ice cream and it is so good it's
like it's good for the same reasons it's
good that when you put pret
excuse me pretzels and ice cream it's a
similar thing where it's like you're
getting like this
salty
savoriness but in a creamy ice cream or
whatever but they sent me all these i
had to go dairy free this time around
because oh did you bring me my you said
you were gonna bring me the everything i
forgot i'm sorry
i'm sorry yeah i didn't open my
everything this time i got it last time
i'm gonna still have it yeah all right
well then next time you see this is
haunting me though dude like i would
like to like every night i'm like i
can't i can't go in after this ice cream
again
and every night i do no i i gotta do
special occasions i go in on it they
sent me a sheet cake it was called texas
sheet cake jenny's did yeah and it was
like jenny's is getting to the sheet
cake no no the flavor of ice cream oh
it's called texas sheet cake and it was
chocolate chic cake flavor
and then it had like icing in it but
when you ate the ice cream the icing was
still dripping i don't know how they do
it it was crazy
it was crazy it was so good dude
you think they're looking for a taste
buds flavor
wow
jenny's
people tag jenny's on your socials
someone sent him a clip of this yeah
tell them we want to do a taste buds
flavor flavor
salty and sweet charity yeah a charity
flavor based on salty salty and sweet
okay yeah that's right salty and sweet
yeah something that combines salty and
sweet yeah
for charity yeah come on jenny's come on
we know you want to
dennis come on
hey i'm the sweet one
oh man wouldn't that rule if we had a
taste buds flavor for jenny's yes it
would roll i mean honestly that's like
that's why i made it we had to initiate
the fan base yes go to jenny's tell them
run don't walk to jew boy sandwiches and
also
tell jenny's that they you guys want to
see burgers burgers oh what i say
sandwiches all right yeah yeah uh yeah
well you know and if they want to check
our portfolio we have our own peanut
butter yes we do and i have my own beer
yes you do and i have my own bar and
sandwiches there it is it's all set
we're in this game hot dogs where are we
at
right now like 28 minutes let's go to
the phones no let's talk butcher box
sally babes oh i love butcher box and
i'll tell you why okay first of all i
like being ethical and they source
ethical uh and sustainable product uh
which often tastes better when it's at
high quality of level right uh it makes
it easy to prep because i they send me
my box it comes with like 9 to 14 pounds
of meat i throw all that stuff in the
freezer and then whenever i want to pick
a protein that i want to cook with that
night i have it in stock that's not
really my mentality when i go to a
supermarket i'm not going and looking up
every single type of frozen food and
it's a subscription service and you can
pause it whenever you want so it's not
like you're going to sign up and then
get sent stuff when you don't want it
anymore uh it's my favorite part of
butch box is the is personally the
steaks i love that they have uh
as you said ethically sourced steak uh
but also it's you know grass-fed and
it's affordable and it's wonderful and i
it's just my favorite thing i love steak
and this pla this butcher box makes it
not only affordable to eat steak but
also let you eat steak in the healthiest
way possible
yeah and i like you said the beef is
free range i recently made chicken that
was organic by the way it was larange if
you're asking uh the seafood is wild and
more and more and more every month
butcher box ships curated selections of
high quality meat right to your home
free shipping for for the continent of
the united states uh and i think you
could also customize the box there are
no antibiotics no added hormones uh 8 to
14 pounds of meat on that mother uh for
24 individual meals they're packed fresh
they're shipped frozen for your
convenience uh that's it it's your
chance if you never had to shop a ground
beef again oh because of this
this is the deal this is your chance to
never have to shop for ground beef ever
again
that's right butcher box is giving new
members free ground beef for life as
long as you stay subscribed plus you get
ten dollars off with a special coupon
they're gonna send you so sign up at
butcherbox.com taste buds and get two
pounds of crown pee free
in every order for life of your
membership plus the ten dollars off
coupon
log on to butcherbox.com taste buds
claim this deal joey you know i have a
peloton since september i love it i use
it because it keeps the workouts fresh
and exciting to me uh when i'm done with
an instructor i'm like later for you and
then i find a new instructor and
everyone has their own personality their
own works flow they all play different
types of music so it's not just getting
on the bike to nothing it's not just
getting on the bike to the same workout
video day in and day out it's really
cool you feel like you're part of a
community um i'd go as far as say a new
instructor leads to a new you oh that we
should we should we should call them up
and ask them if they want to buy that
from us
peloton's pushing you further but they
have much more now uh new on the peloton
bike and the peloton bike plus new
classes new music new ways to keep your
workouts fun and motivating they have
new additions uh in 2022 boxing is on
there they're stepping it up with
in-ring uh stuff
no gloves needed of course but uh if you
never box before the classes will have
you up and working up a sweat while
working on fundamentals and form of
boxing and footwork that's kind of cool
yeah it's like i guess it's like almost
like a shadow boxing kind of thing yes
which is very very cool because then
nobody gets hurt nobody gets hurt just
you in the shadow new artist series
music selections uh they're adding new
artists all the time more daily workout
variety it's easier to stick to your
goals when you keep workouts interesting
that's true peloton has a workout for
every day and every schedule you could
de-stress from a long day with the 30
minute strength or you get 20 minutes of
cardio you can even do a quick 15-minute
total body class
before
before work even everyone could fit 15
minutes in stay motivated while having
fun with bike workouts yoga meditation
dance cardio and more visit
onepeleton.com to learn more that is
o-n-e-p-e-l-o-t-o-n.com
[Music]
all right let's go let's get into it
dogs versus chicks yeah and we got a new
thing we're going to do
we felt sal and i've been talking that
we've had some great episodes lately but
we feel that some of the vigor not vigor
that's wrong
the venom has been defused by the no
matter what happens i love you chance
now we still love each other no matter
what happens and we're still going to
chant that once in a while because we
also have to sell merch but
you came today and you wanted to do an
anti no matter what we got to start
doing a chant that spins that riles us
up against each other
so here's what we're going to
do the new chant is
it's time to get salty
all right
now how this works is
how this works is
we're each
we're going to do it together yeah
a lot of the original chant yeah
you say it three times it's time to get
salty it's time to get salty it's time
to get salty
but here's the difference
we take we
[Music]
did we take turns yeah we do this chant
twice
the first time we do it three no no we
do it no no i'm saying we do the
okay say it three times that's one
chance okay but we do the chat twice
the first time we do it coming off of
the third one one of us insults the
other
dude i think you're part native american
with these chairs
and we and we stay on that for a minute
yeah and then we do it again and the
other person gets to assault the other
okay and then at the end at the end of
that minute at the end of that minute of
the second chant we go right into the
battle okay and the way we're going to
time these lebs
yes the way we're going to time this is
this is what the pots and pans are we're
giving these off to v
and pimp when we hit a minute on each of
these
you gotta you gotta ding ding ding ding
ding ding ding for a full minute oh you
wanna make it 30 seconds yeah all right
30 seconds okay
right
we're
and when it's time for the battle they
bang the pots and pans like they do at
pamplona in the running of the bulls
okay so i i wanted you to have a chance
to retort so i shall but i i thought
that they banged the pots and pans i
think so we've got to time the the back
and forth of the retort because okay
that can't go on for five minutes no i
thought it was like i thought it was
like a line all right 30 seconds ready
ready yeah yeah are you ready are you
gonna insult me first then okay just to
show you how it works
all right are we holding it no no no
ready all right you ready
here you are ready ready ready
it's time to get salty it's time to get
salty it's time to get salty your house
rule of taking your shoes off is stupid
ow are you serious yes well you would
like to be chasing around and cocaine
and [ __ ] everywhere yeah i'd like to
like to walk like a grown-up through the
house oh yeah baby give me a break
here we can't afford a cleaning stand we
eat here and we sleep here we eat off
the floor we eat here we see it it's
stupid you want to put the soles of your
shoes go everywhere on this earth you
want to put them on my carpet i'm going
to tell you something are you wild it
influences the interest in a visit i'm
just going to put that out there are you
serious
[Music]
you don't take your shoes off
you talked about it well i'm not alone
i'm not alone i'm in the majority most
people that are sane people now all
right now it's your turn that's your
turn really now it's your turn ready
oh
what's your house like this [ __ ]
don't ruin it don't don't ruin ready
ready
it's time to get salty it's time to get
salty it's time to get salty you're
[ __ ] ridiculous wearing socks that
are dry gin socks enough with alcohol
you consume it enough it doesn't need to
be on your fashion okay i put your foot
up and i see the word gin we know you're
a drunk you don't have to advertise it
your feet aren't billboards
i'm only wearing these socks because i
gotta wear designer socks ever coming
from your house because you're dumb
those shoes roll
that's stupid
i wish i could just wear a plain black
sock in this place you can't do it
everybody's looking at my feet the whole
time we're playing black socks can you
judge yourself playing social people
with tuxedos i'm getting judged in my
foot fashion in this place oh god
are you saying that you don't have the
confidence as an adult male to reach
into a sock drawer and know that
whatever you pull out is going to be
presentable no you're walking around
with hold socks black sock is
presentable when you're walking around
with no shoes on for hours on end you
got to have this fancy sock on a fancy
sock kind of a pattern is what i'm
saying whose house do you go to that
lets you walk around with shoes the
animal everybody no that's not true
that's not true you walk around your
house you walk
all right here we go b-a-t-t-l-e
buds all right
[Laughter]
i can't believe you got the balls to
come on here which you try to put the
chicken finger against the hot dog you
are insane yeah i think you're insane i
think you're interesting i think that i
think that uh chicken figure probably
stands on the
upper echelon of everything with pizza
french fries chicken fingers it's almost
like it's it's you can't beat chicken
fingers most chicken fingers are bad
most
most i'm not exaggerating
we're talking trash food we're talking
fried food we're not gonna talk bad
chicken fingers no no chicken fingers
are chicken fingers no no you're not
you're not you're not hearing what i'm
saying it's all i get it it's all bar
room food i'm not saying that chicken
fingers should be fancy i'm saying most
chicken fingers are bad because most of
the time when you get them it's too much
breading and dry ass chicken most of the
time chicken fingers throw it out the
window right because everybody knows
that and nobody cares chicken fingers
checks a box for everyone the same exact
way it's goddamn chicken fingers i'm not
expecting much even when it's not that
good it's still kind of good there's a
lot of great dipping sauces i even get
it from fast food restaurants to fancy
places it's just chicken fingers it's
good from the kids menu to the people
the old people with no teeth menu and
chicken fingers there's no one that does
with no teeth man yeah like chicken
fingers nuts that's you can't eat it i'm
just gonna sit here if you don't have
good teeth chicken you gotta gnarl
through that thing you know that come on
dude don't say crazy i'm not gonna sit
here and go to war about whether you
have to gnarls through them at an older
age all i'm saying is chicken fingers
appeals to 99.9
of people hot dogs do not
hot dogs by the way are just i don't
even know what's in them but if i take
five guesses they're all not gonna be
good i think it's like like ass
lips
hoofs
intestines look we all know that there's
just stuff laying around
listen we all know that whole thing but
i'll tell you this
hot dogs contain not only some of the
most disgusting ingredients turned into
a substance resembling pink slime but
also nitrates which have been linked to
type 2 diabetes
processed meats maybe me too including
hot dogs are also in the same uh
carcinogenic category as cigarettes and
increase your risk of cancer so that
just goes along with the hot dog okay
but honestly how many how many dogs are
people eating that they're getting
cancer from hot dogs
if i order a chicken fingers right i
could have six 10 chicken fingers right
how many hot 10 well depends on the size
right like no they're they come in one
pretty standard size i'm helping i could
eat five right okay yeah how many hot
dogs are you putting down before you
just start regurgitating like hot dogs
unidentified if i make am i making a
meal of the hot dogs or a snack
i'm serious how many for me am i sitting
down for a lunch or dinner or a hot dog
lunch all right so one is a snack three
you eat three hot dogs
hot dogs
is what's on the menu for dinner you eat
three i eat three with sides
three with sides three with sides so
you're going to eat one with a side
another with a side and i'm saying i put
i make three hot dogs and then i have
baked beans and fries or whatever i've
ever seen dogs is i think a little over
i think it's a bit much i'll tell you
two dogs i think is where people it's
two dogs that's what a lot of people do
you ask me what i do you didn't ask me
what the average person does you said
specifically what do i do three dogs
by the end of that third dog you're not
like oh
like everything about you is not like
you don't have the meat sweats and your
stomach's trying to you're not trying to
[ __ ] no digestion quality hot dog
myself you you you eat one hot dog if i
eat one hot dog i'm burping up a hot dog
i'm not kidding you if i eat a hot dog
on monday afternoon thursday i'll burp
you oh god that hot dog you're not
eating quality hot dogs or you're you
have a digestive issue
what your dad said ballpark frank's he
says that he likes 100 beef is that is
that a quality hot dog in your opinion i
don't need ball parks but what's a
quality hot dog in your opinion uh i
love the apple gate i i look for i i
look for an uncured no nitrates added
dog if i can find one if i can't find an
uncured i'll go cured but like something
with no i look for little ingredients
okay just like you would with a sausage
if you go to buy an italian sausage you
look for a brand that doesn't have a
shitload of ingredients in it and you go
all right this is this is as good as
you're gonna get you know that's what i
look for but a ballpark i'm not i'm not
i'm not batting my i'm not waving my
turn in my nose too you you must know
that i probably have had a fine dog i'll
eat a hot i'll not every dog i've had
has been trained oscar meyer cheese dog
i love those you just said you eat top
quality sang i'm saying i'll go at all
of them you're asking me if what i
prefer
that makes me feel like less guilty
about the indulgence i look for a
non-cured
no nitrates but i will eat other dogs
i i'm telling you right now oh is there
a cheese in this hot dog yeah that's
disgusting
cheese all over your face so good dude
oh that looks so gross look at that it's
so good i probably i'm sure it is ham
one i'm sure it's like guilty good but
like i don't want to bite into a hot dog
and have like liquid ooze out on on me
you know like because you haven't done
it yeah i'm telling you if you do it
you're gonna like it
i'll tell you the biggest problem with
chicken fingers if you don't have a good
dipping sauce you're out if you have a
good hot dog you can eat it without
without anything on it uh and anything
you put on it is probably all going to
enhance some people say deplete from the
experience chicken fingers if you do not
have good dipping sauce there's no way
you're eating more than how could you go
ahead you just say that when you tell me
that oh you're just eating bad hot dogs
and i'm going to give you the same
argument back that you're just eating
bad chicken fingers when i have a
perfectly breaded juicy succulent
chicken finger i could eat it without a
sauce i've done that my whole life
your whole life my whole life your whole
life my whole life your whole life so
you're going into a bar i'm not like you
i was eating chicken fingers at three
not turf
not surf and turf i'll tell you the
other the other tell that the hot dog is
the superior food number one there's hot
dog eating contests everywhere oh that's
a chicken finger contest no that's it
yeah no it means it's popular enough
that you can base a contest around it i
got a pie eating contest what other food
art contests are there pie eating hot
dog eating two hugely popular foods
there's no chicken fingers do not i do
not even think you're going to be i
think you you are not going to win this
i think chicken finger
guys
dog have you ever heard of nathan's yeah
i watch every single year kobayashi
johnny sunsets whatever his name is hot
wings is another
uh food eating contest let me ask you
guys just just in general do you think
cause they're both big big foods
what do you think is the uh is the uh
favorite out of these two do you think
it is hot dog i happen to think that
chicken fingers are appealed to way more
people than hot dogs do
i thought that i think more people live
their lives on chicken fingers correct
yeah people i mean that's the go-to you
go to a diner you chicken fingers you
don't order a hot dog in a diner let me
tell you you go to mcdonald's you get
chicken tenders you don't get a hot dog
there's no hot dog on the dollar menu
well what what dollar menu there's no
chicken finger on the dollar minion well
even even you've got nuggets on a dollar
menu not fingers even in a real life
scenario well you even in a real life
scenario if you're at a barbecue and
you're throwing a dog on there people
are also throwing chicken on there
no no they're throwing chicken not
chicken fingers
don't act like barbecues yeah but they
could be stopping no but they could be
grilled no no no i i put i've put uh
what do you call that when you when you
when you not marinate with your face i
swear to god is he going to go into
unbreaded chicken fingers are you out of
your mind i was going oh stop it sal
you're reaching you're reading that's
not a chicken finger that's a piece of
chicken grilled chicken fingers okay
then look up grilled chicken fingers i
want to see if it even comes up it's not
it's not a thing
it's not i've never even seen it in a
restaurant ever
look at this
chicken tenders they call them it's
different it's just it just it just
exists then no see
that's grilled chicken tenders do you
see grilled chicken fingers anywhere you
see bread you're telling me the
difference between a tender and a finger
clearly a tender and a finger is the
same thing
chicken tender chicken finger versus
tender chicken tender refers to chicken
prepared for the more tender part of
chicken commonly uh the whatever that
says
on the other hand chicken fingers refers
to strips of chicken meat derived from
the chicken breast or the inner breast
muscle there's your difference there's
no such thing as a breadless chicken
finger because if there was it would
have came up as breadless chicken finger
and not chicken tenders let's go to some
of these stats
what's your what's the most wonder one
to his first popularity yeah popularity
statistics reported that 182
0.91 million americans used frozen fried
chicken in 2018
73 million americans consumed chicken
nuggets in 2020. according to statistics
255 million americans consume
frankfurters and hot dogs in 2020. so by
that stat alone it looks like you're the
more popular food
okay and can i say something else let me
ask you something what's it what's it
there you know hot dog and a frankfurter
frank furter and then also how did it
get the name hot talk
well hot dogs here
can i tell you something else too maybe
let me tell you something else because
these are childhood foods
that become popular when you're a child
in your life
and some people carry on with them
throughout their lives some people don't
here's the biggest difference
if you go on a date with a woman for
instance
and you you hold on hold on you're
bringing a date
with a woman into chicken tenders versus
hot dogs yeah let me finish okay fingers
don't say tenders don't change what
we're talking about to fit your bad
argument fingers if you go on a date
with a woman
and you go to get food and and you order
a hot dog to eat
she's gonna think man this guy's old
school he's eating a hot dog wow
whether she's done whether she's
gonna think unless whether she's
impressed or not is besides the point
she's gonna be like this guy's kind of
old-school she's got a hot dog if you go
on a date and you order chicken fingers
she'll be like i'm never having sex with
this man i i just
disagree with a baby child flip it smack
it down flip and reverse it she's gonna
go does he does he want the chicken
shaped like stars this child nobody
wants to have sex with a guy that eats
chicken you're a lunatic nobody wants to
flip it and reverse it you a million
people go on dates and order chicken
fingers together and share them with
their meal if i went on a date with a
woman and i sat down and the waiter came
over and i go i'll have the hot dog and
whatever she's having she would think
the exact same way she's like she
wouldn't go oh he's old school she would
go what the [ __ ] is going on she might
say he's ordering a hot dog dinner she
might be confused imagine ordering for
her she might do hot dogs please one for
me and a lady should not be perplexed
she might be perplexed she might be
confused she might think it's strange
she'll still have sex with you chicken
fingers
she will not have sex with you if you
order a hot dog she will not have sex
with you you know what
you're not having sex if you order a hot
dog you know what else is a cute date
move we're in the park oh want to get a
hot dog wouldn't it be fun to go to the
hot dog stand nobody on a date goes oh
wanna go get chicken fingers cause
you're in the park though you're in the
park
there's hot dogs carts cause that's not
fair that's how popular that food is
they've got parts of it on the
street joey i want you i want you to go
you're a single guy you're in a dating
pool i want you to go on your very next
date i don't want you to say a word to
the woman i don't want you to say a word
to the woman i want you to order a hot
dog from the menu for dinner order what
she wants to order you tell me later you
even cut your breast over the shirt my
hand to god i will order a hot dog on
the next date i'm on you will not yes i
will don't go to nathan's don't play by
the way that's not me saying and i will
have sex at the end of the day i'm
saying i'm just saying i will order a
hot dog on that date and the date will
will be successful or unsuccessful but
not based on that hot dog it will yes it
will we need photo proof yes all right
you you cannot you could not let the gun
i
promise you i can get you full of proof
that she thinks it's endearing that i'm
eating a hot dog oh you're full of [ __ ]
how could you get photo proof that your
date thinks it's endearing that you're
eating a hot dog how how can you get
food smiling with a hot dog oh you're
not supposed to say anything to her i i
gotta say i'm ordering a hot dog and
then and you think i'm gonna take
yourself okay
it'll be fun you think you're gonna
order a hot dog and then snap a candid
photo of her delighted that you did it i
should let's take a selfie with the hot
dog
why not you that's no you know what's
not we want you to lady and [ __ ] the
hot dog
oh my god
sometimes i care i can do it i can't do
it with this kid sometimes i can't do it
with this kid sometimes i can't do it
with this kid sometimes i can't do it
with this kid sometimes
i promise you i can pull off a lady in a
[ __ ] photo
with a woman who has not heard this
episode
of a hot dog between our lips i don't
think you know look look man all i'm
saying is if you're an adult you're an
adult look you let people walk in the
house with shoes you're an adult right
yeah yeah you go on a date and it's at a
rest at a regular place and you go first
of all a regular place isn't going to
have a hot dog if we'll being honest you
have to go to like a very like you know
i got a friend
i get it casual place i get it it ain't
going to be a problem babe they're on
every corner that's how powerful if
you're going to go to a place that has a
bunch of hot stoves on the menu
no no i don't you don't go with her to a
hot dog cart that's normalizing it you
said if you ordered the house you said
you if you ordered a hot dog off the
menu you're changing the game now
go to a regular restaurant and ask for a
hobby somewhere that has hot dogs well
you're gonna go to a hot dog restaurant
it's not gonna be weird that you order a
hot dog
what i'm not gonna go to a hot dog
restaurant if you go to a hot dog you'll
spring the hot dog on her out of nowhere
so if we're walking by a car i'm gonna
go like this i'm gonna go joe you can't
if you say someone uh you want to grab a
hot dog from the hotdog cart that's
normal
that's normal you said to me okay if
you're on a date with a woman and you
order a hot dog
off the table
her to a diner which is gonna put me in
the underhanded position or under a dog
position to begin with because it looks
like i'm being cheap
but you're about to eat [ __ ] ass and
lips in a [ __ ] link
what do you mean you're about you're
ordering a dollar meal this is supposed
to come from i know go to a diner let
her order first oh she should own a
first or second here's what i'm gonna do
here's what you're gonna do i will go to
a real restaurant and during the real
meal i'm gonna go
i'm craving a hot dog i want to get a
hot dog after this no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no
what you're doing right there and
self-admittedly doing is you are
you're prepping you're you're you're not
saying you're making orders you're
embracing her and you're making it okay
you are ashamed you're
i wish they had hot dogs here i would
eat hot dogs no no qualifiers
no yes it is she the waitress says hi
i'm june i'll be your servant tonight
won't you like you go i have the hot dog
please and shut the [ __ ] up where am i
gonna go then there's hot dogs don't do
it don't do the [ __ ] song and dance
you know what i'm you know whatever you
gotta eat in the cart that's what i'm
saying no go to a diner order a hot dog
say nothing of it i can't take a first
date to a diner it's gonna look insane
but you could order a hot dog on the
first date that's the point is that the
hot dog part i think i could this
it's not how you brought it up you said
you'd order a hot dog off the menu now
you're going to a cart now you're going
you know you want to get something
i'll find it i'm going to order a dog
i'll find a place that has like like
like you know
gourmet uh bar food or whatever
that normalizes i think we're
overlooking one thing she might not look
at it as old school and attractive she
might think she can fix you right hey
god bless nobody's fixing chicken
fingers
nobody's fixing chicken fingers you will
look like an ass if you eat them on a
date no as a matter of fact not only
will you look like not look like an ass
but i think that many dates especially
if younger people are chicken fingers at
the gate out the gate sharing them as a
meal or or ordering them to come for the
table
you're if you order chicken fingers
not a single person would ever bat an
eyelash on a date if you say i'll have a
hot dog at a restaurant she's going to
be like oh i don't know what i'm getting
myself into here no restaurant has hot
dogs
you said they did
the eight best foods to order on a first
date here we go let's see him
i'm sweating my [ __ ] bowls yeah maybe
you could take
i was going to ask you if you could take
some of that money you're saving on your
floor cleaning and put it into air
conditioning in this place because i'm
sweating my ass i don't need to clean my
floors because everyone's just touching
it with soft cotton that's my j that's
my point is that you're not spending any
money on cleaning the floor chicken is
one of the chicken not chicken fingers
idiot
[Laughter]
risotto what is this list quesadilla
i'm gonna talk about ultimate ears some
really cool new headphones out there on
the market
uh
here's the thing i use technology daily
i cannot think of an hour in the day
where i'm not using my macbook pro or my
ipad or my iphone and it's not just for
fun it's for work and a lot of it is is
administrative stuff and and
work-related stuff that you have to do
while you're at home at least for me
that's how it is so i it's very
important to me to have a device that i
can switch freely easily from thing to
thing with but i will tell you even more
what if you're have those buds in all
day because my buds that came on my
phone fall out all the time and then the
other pair i have are actually too big
and they're they're hurt and that's
what's that's what's cool about their
ultimate ears they mold to your ear yeah
they're true wireless custom fit earbuds
and they they come it's really cool and
you actually put the mold in and they go
exactly to your shape yeah so that it is
a perfect fit bespoke to your ear it
creates a custom fit you put them in and
you follow the steps in the app and you
can feel them forming uh it actually
gets warm as the as the uh i guess
rubber or whatever it is the material
sort of molding to the shape of your ear
and that's it you put them in and i also
like you pop it and you turn it and it
kind of like locks it in a certain way
very cool
great sound also not like crazy noise
canceling sound which has always been
freaky to me i've never been a big fan
of that style of earbud
uh you get a guaranteed perfect fit in
60 seconds ultimate ears fits and will
stay put when you're on the go eight
hours of continuous playback on a single
charge 20 hours up to 20 hours with the
charging case ultimate ears fits are
perfect for listening to your favorite
shows like ours you can also custom uh
eq presets as well yeah which uh you
cannot do on
most
most other earbuds at all i don't even
know nearby that you can do that no i
agree so use the promo code tastebuds at
ue.com
fits to get your pair of ue fits that's
ue.com
fits promo code taste buds try the fits
if you don't love them as much as we do
no worries ultimate ears offers a 30 day
money back guarantee plus you're going
to get free shipping free returns and a
one-year warranty here's how you get
that use your promo code taste buds at
ue.com fits
and get your pair of uefits with these
benefits i just mentioned go to ue.com
fits promo code taste buds folks we got
a new cereal sponsor they're called
catalina crunch yeah baby cool right yes
i only there's yeah i just only recently
got into this yeah it's new to me very
very new to me but i have tried it i've
been eating it for a bit and i like it i
like what it's doing it's one of these
cereals that is letting you eat cereal
again which i stopped cereal is my
favorite food yeah i stopped it i was
just on vacation i just ate sugar cereal
which i haven't done a long time but
this is zero sugar low carb keto
friendly uh they they have tons of
flavors and you can buy a variety pack
if you want to see which one you like uh
first
and most by the way most zero sugar
not just zero sugar sugar cereals but
mostly zero sugar foods they don't don't
taste no they they did this the right
way it's actually delicious uh 11 grams
of plant-based protein and nine grams of
fiber so
you can't really go wrong there at all
it's actually a lot of flavors eight i
think eight or so they got cinnamon
toast they got chocolate uh dark
chocolate they got a chocolate peanut
butter which i like uh so you know if
you're not sure by the way which one you
want to try first you can get variety
pack as well gluten free it's grain free
it's non-gmo
only real only clean ingredients nothing
artificial so here's what you're gonna
do we want you to see why catalina's
crunch cereal is the fastest growing
cereal brand in america go to catalina
crunch.com slash taste buds for 15 off
your first order
plus free shipping that's catalina with
a c
crunch.com
slash taste buds
not sure what flavor to start with again
try that variety pack people go and
check out their delicious cookies and
snack mixes while you're at it
catalinacrunch.com taste buds for 15 off
your first order plus free
all right can i can we go back with him
for a moment
uh the term dog
has been just i want you to answer to
this because it's definitely true the
term dog has been used as a synonym for
sausage since the 800s possibly uh from
accusations that sausage makers use dog
meat in their sausages
yeah in the 1700's who cares what are we
talking about in germany the consumption
of dog meat was common
uh
the suspicion that sausages contain dog
meat was occasionally justified so the
reason that you're eating something
called a hot dog is because back in the
day they've only ju you're only a few
you're only a few
a few
a few ingredients removed from dog bro
it used to be dog now it's not dogs it
started with dog it says it was a theory
that it might have been daunting so
you're eating the descendant you're
eating the ancestor you're eating the
evolution of dog that's what you're
eating it's like well we can't give
people dog meat it's frowned upon
whatever you want
that [ __ ] up put it through the grinders
which chicken fingers derived from
aside from the hackiest joke of all time
but it must have been some big chicken
look at its fingers
uh
uh scott scotland how are there for uh
scots began immigration
you have to read those so people can
understand what you said
chicken fingers gave popularity in the
mid to late 1980s
known also as one of the worst periods
of the country period one of the worst
mid 1980s one of the worst periods of
country it's everyone's favorite reagan
president
chicken fingers popularity in the mid
80s to reaganomics nobody ever why
nobody's nobody ever looks back at the
80s and goes that was a real brilliant
time in this country the 80s is in the
80s is arguably top three most
romanticized decade of all time top two
possibly listen i got no beef with the
80s you know me i love the 80s all right
but it's not a it's not it's not
romanticized for its brilliance it
wasn't the renaissance in the united
states
i'm saying it was it was like they blame
the 80s for like the the the influx of
fast food and like the diet going to
[ __ ] in this country all that you're
arguing for a dog bro a hot dog i'm just
telling you that's when you're that's
when your food came into prominence
mine's been around since kings do you
understand i understand
hot dogs were fit for royalty etcetera
one of the pages we were just on not to
mention pigs in a blanket the greatest
cocktail food of all time bro back to
[ __ ] if you don't if i can't bring in
a grilled chicken tender
you can't bring in a pigs in a blanket
no it's not a hot dog it would just like
you said a belgian waffle was a waffle
yeah and you said a crepe with a pancake
so whatever you want to do all right
let's go to the phones
you know how many
just one last thing
a hot dog burp
is the worst burp known to man yes or no
true or false
it's the worst burp there is
just saying that no one's like oh gee
chicken fingers okay and i'll tell you
i'll tell you what a ranch stain on your
shirt from your chicken finger dripping
is the worst stain known to man when i
you could have any stain on your shirt
if you go it's ranch i'm like you piece
of [ __ ]
it's garbage i don't even really shades
blood i'd rather you go i don't eat
ranch though they'd say it's a ranch
thing i don't eat ranch for my chickens
a lot of people do and that's what i'm
telling you all right a lot of people
give you know how many
tonka is very sweet and she's probably
my biggest fan she says yeah many foods
are shaped like dicks the best kinds
her name is not tonka by the way that's
a reference to my show i played a
character named tonka john cherish i'm
sorry oh okay cherish
uh
food shaped like a dickway how many food
shaped like a dick the best kinds all
right shout outs hot dogs if
hot dogs worst part of the animal ground
up and shoved into its own intestines
and top of it all let's make it dick
shape so what i'm saying bro oh look at
that there's a picture of sal eating a
hot dog
[Laughter]
i'm not eating a hot dog i'm making one
cause i worked at a hot dog cart yo you
mean the most the the weird carts that
are all over the city for highly
demanded for food
uh
hot dogs are like drugs you get from the
sketchy friend of a friend that you can
only buy because it's cheap and you
don't care what's in it you just need a
fix
only the lord knows what
that's a lot to describe the hot tub the
best hot dogs are as good as the best
chicken fingers but the worst hot dog
makes you want to bleach your own
insides true i can't argue with that
chicken fingers and what barbecue sauce
with hot dogs condiments are endless
kraut oh my god he's right jesus
tremendous right i didn't even bring in
bacon wrapped hot dogs
oh the chicago dog with the hot peppers
all right fried chicken with a multitude
of sauces versus animal intestines on a
dirty shitty roll there's one choice
here whoever got roped into having to
take hot dogs in this battle must have
known what was coming to them but no
moral victories for the buds there you
go chicken all day did you even mention
corn dogs it's kind of like best of both
worlds yeah corn dogs are great well a
hot dog is a hot dog a corn dog is a
corn dog if you step up to a menu and
say i'll have a hot dog then i'll hand
you a corn dog all right fair enough
fair enough i voted chicken fingers but
immediately regret that i do a michigan
coney over chicken fingers all day way
more versatility in a hot dog absolutely
that's what i'm saying processed hooves
over the lightly delightfully crispy
breading
ah chickens don't even have fingers this
is just like a gaggle of hacky
commentaries
anus snout odds and ends yeah i'll take
chicken fingers i mean that's what it
boils down it's just everybody just
keeps saying the same it's just not even
true like it's the joke from the great
outdoors they're made out of lips and
[ __ ] like but it's true it's
but it is true it's true to an extent
and it was more true uh years ago than
it is now but i mean it's just the fact
that people are just leaning on that
give me a break come on i don't buy
dirty water chicken tenders wow that's a
good point that's a rake that's a good
point that's an original point i'm
already hearing two different battles
where sal defends both hot dogs and
chicken fingers
i more often will take chicken fingers
or hot dogs but sometimes i really crave
the hot dogs like right now
uh only people who enjoy hot dogs are
children oh it's just not true it's not
true
i doubt there's a hot dog version of the
gift just saying
what's the gift
that
disco chickens
oh boy
hot dogs are my favorite food said no
one ever if you're choosing hot dogs
over chicken fingers i need you to
reevaluate your life
joe's the type of person that has seen
what hot dogs are made of and still
chooses to defend it good point hot dogs
are ground up lips and [ __ ]
almost every restaurant has chips almost
every restaurant has chicken fingers on
a menu for adults and kids alike hot
dogs are very situational ball game kids
menus is dirty water too dirty can't
argue so true at all by the way have you
ever had the chicken fingers at a movie
theater versus hot dogs however the
chicken fingers in a ball game versus
the hot dogs it it it's not even a
comparison there's not even comparison
in quality
i really hope joe didn't take hot dogs
this is what i mean by the way that
they're guessing what i took
to and it's influencing the vote a
hundred percent
no they don't they're not voting on who
they think we took how many people how
many people have said already oh joe
with the hot dog how many people have
said that already we should everyone
comment who's spiding spidey it's like
come on man you think there's spite
votes not a thousand 65 episodes in
guessing
so they're not even sure they're
guessing and they're going to spitefully
vote have you seen what they think have
you seen one tweet that is guess what
you voted versus several that i did i
did see me but you could already see it
now south saying how hot dogs are
americana i didn't choose hot dogs okay
but my point is is how many have we seen
so sal better be fighting for a hot dog
pimp back me up am i crazy come on
there's like this is perfect
vote yeah
yes that's all i'm saying chicken
figures for children but if you're
eating a hot dog anywhere
but a barbecue or a baseball game you
need to take a long look in the mirror
and reasses we're not talking oh this is
what i hate when people say [ __ ] like
this we're not talking about what
environment you're eating it in we're
talking about the actual food itself
there's a reason that hot dogs are a
cornerstone at every single barbecue and
every single baseball game and every
single movie theater and every single
state fair and every single vendor
across every single city there's a
reason for that it's because it's an
awesome food it doesn't matter if you
occasionally want it or want it every
day that's irrelevant salty salty salty
chicken fingers are available at every
[ __ ] diner because they are frozen
and mass produced in a factory i love
these [ __ ] idiots talking like
chicken fingers are like quality food
that was fished out of the ocean that's
this morning and then brought for you
[ __ ] farm to table or whatever you
will fall
it's the one of the most processed foods
on earth they're frozen in batches and
they sit in a refrigerator for a year
and then you deep fry the [ __ ] things
i'm not arguing the health of either
that would be ridiculous right all i'm
saying is more often than not even
yourself do you have chicken fingers
more often than hot dogs no yes you do
totally not everyone does hot dogs
regularly do you crazy fridge
outside of the summer at barbecues maybe
at a ball game maybe one other time and
i had to be like oh i can go for a hot
dog but i'm never thinking like i want
to get a hot dog tonight ever thank you
david olson people complaining about hot
dogs being processed meat but then have
the gall to vote for chicken fingers
exactly all right
exactly and by the way and by the way
it's not aka tenders uh susie k we
proved it it's not it's not you're wrong
you're wrong you're wrong all right
uh all right but i'm just gonna say this
i'm just gonna say this i buy hot dogs
all the time like i mean from home i
make them at home i love hot dogs
i love fried chicken i
eat fried chicken consistently i almost
never get that fried chicken in the form
of a chicken finger i think chicken is
one of those foods that when it's taken
off the bone it loses a great deal of
quality it dries out it loses its
juiciness and not to mention
that chicken fingers being made from
white meat chicken it's the toughest
part of the chicken if it's not cooked
right which chicken fingers are not
cooked right okay it's got no fat i'm
not going to argue this like we argue
gourmet foods
versus hot dogs i got you i so no i
don't i never crave chicken fingers okay
yeah i think you're in the middle of
that sure because nuggets have some dark
meat action going on a lot of the time a
nugget is a finger bro no it's not a
nugget is for all intents and purposes a
nugget is a finger bro my biggest
complaint about about my favorite
mcdonald's my biggest complaint about
chicken mcnuggets which is one of my
favorite foods on earth is that they got
rid of the dark meat nuggets because the
dark meat nuggets kill that's not a
chicken what is a nugget then if it's
not a tender or a finger
well sometimes dark it's a lot of times
nuggets are taken from dark meat chicken
which is why they're like so juicy and
whatever you don't you consider a
chicken nugget different than a chicken
finger 100
nuggets a lot of time are less breaded
chicken fingers are too [ __ ] breaded
a lot of the time i think all right so
do we have a winning tweet here
you can eat chicken fingers at parties
with friends when i eat hot dogs i don't
like talking about it all right yeah
that's funny yeah give it to jeff
follow at mr green arrow and let's go to
the polls all right let's go to the
phones it's a humble pie segment drum
roll it may be a pot and pan
yeah
we're at 13 000 votes
[Laughter]
uh i think we're going to lose that's
for the results and for the frontline
workers yes
given the comments i think i'm gonna
lose but let's see i i i honestly think
i don't know what you were thinking i
think chicken figures is a powerhouse
oh my god that's ridiculous oh is it or
did you just did your world just crash
down around you it didn't crash down on
me i just go order a hot dog on a date
you [ __ ] i just
i just realized every week how many fans
we have
they didn't know i was choosing chicken
just realized every week how many fans
we have that live in states where a good
restaurant is considered applebee's
like you could tell you can tell
wouldn't that make hotels
wouldn't that make hot dogs stronger for
you hot dogs applebee's hot dogs are
more of a city food and we know it
the uh hot dog is the city food people
were saying you can get chicken fingers
on any menu
name five restaurants on the top of your
head that sell chicken figures that
aren't kfc or popeyes nah you go to you
go to a diner a bar and grill a bar and
grill has them all the time
all right a bar and grill yeah that's
one but they don't have hot dogs on
menus
no barn girls nobody has they have
hamburger sections they do not have hot
dog sections i know it got heated i know
it got heated but let me just throw can
i go back to that percentage please
because i want to just put it on the
bottom here it's it's a drubbing it's a
drubbing and it is a big it's a lopsided
vic it's 13 200 votes at the moment 70.7
for chicken fingers 29.3 for hot dogs it
wasn't
even
close
all right
well
there you go
i still love you babe i love you too
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds